[Music]
and around the back Kelly said born and
raised because it was the only set
available for filming today we welcome
to to our new show smashing a show we
made up to talk about movies and to
waste money on commemorative plates up
today Jaden's dad has he made more good
movies more bad movies we're gonna talk
about him tally up the scores and see if
this plate gets smashed or forgets its
place on the touch of you know pretty
goodness
yo plate smash you later is Will Smith
the biggest movie star of all time he
was at one time the biggest movie star
in the planet not anymore but he was I
still in my mind think Tom Cruise the
Will Smith is right I mean he's in the
conversation you should be in the
conversation I'm not 100% convinced I
think Will Smith's legacy is number one
how you can start your career in one
point and end it somewhere almost
entirely different he's just one of the
most successful rappers turned actor
turned back rapper does whatever he
wants of all time he's one of the first
guys to ever win a Grammy for the rap
category for hip-hop albums with DJ
Jazzy Jeff were just the creme de la
creme and then the will nem you know y2k
stuff my favorite Will Smith song is
summertime some must submit the Scimitar
I'll throw on Big Willie style it's
never gone out of Big Willie style
welcome to Miami bienvenido ami ami the
key to a great song is to have a course
that is mostly just nonsense no no no no
no no getting jiggy with it is a spirit
it's not self-expression that's what
Will Smith wants for us my doctor told
me I'll be very young age I should
probably not get jiggy with it I don't
really know any other way than to get
jiggy with it
I got jiggy with it a lot in high school
yeah I'm alive of course I've gotten
jiggy with it I like to keep my jiggy to
the privacy of my own home I like to
think that I've got Jimmy wasn't in
reality maybe once or twice that I
actually
[Music]
hey what's Philadelphia born and raised
on the playground is where I spent most
of my days dad a dad a dad better than
to death when all shootin some b-ball
outside of the school when a couple of
guys ever have to no good started making
trouble in my neighborhood one little
[ __ ] my mom got scared and said I'm not
singing I'm not doing it I was the
hugest Fresh Prince fan it was a great
fish out of water story mixed with a
great family sitcom but you also had
Will Smith's kind of brand of humor this
is not my CD player see cuz my CD player
has the wires on the inside listen the
fashion choices on that were a plus plus
Smithsonian level 90s the iconic wearing
of the school uniform inside out my
jacket is a fashion miracle though isn't
it one time I had Tevin Campbell on
happy burn and I watched that episode
until it wore out the table I always
loved James Avery as Uncle Phil we'll
got on his nerves I loved their
relationship but he he also was really
loving like that just heartbreaking
episode where wills dad leaves him
you don't want me man it's a tie it's
like Uncle Phil Carlton ty I feel like
Carlton is one of those people who
thought he was very worldly and refined
and that was kind of the joke was like
he was not at all
step-by-step instructions for the
Carlton dance is to lose all sense of
rhythm lose all sense of dignity and
just let it fly
[Music]
that's I'm that's iconic honestly
Carlton kind of gives jiggy with it
I met Alphonso Riviera I wanted a
picture with them I was like can we do
the Carlton and he's just like yeah you
know what I don't care if it wasn't
great for him it was great for me there
was some disagreement between will and
the producers and the original Aunt Viv
and then you know miss banks since you
had that baby it's something different
about you they just like replaced our
thinking what we're not gonna notice
that so that's that first time v was for
like four seasons maybe five and then ii
ONVIF took us home or light-skinned on
Vivi's I like the color when I think the
Will Smith I think of Independence Day
if I was gonna started me one sentence
it is aliens attacked the earth and only
what I could stop him is America the
plan to defeat the aliens was to Birol
within the plan to defeat the aliens and
Independence Day was to get Will Smith
who was the best fighter pilot in the
world to blow up their ships would they
blow up the mothership who knows this is
like one of seventeen movies that Will
Smith did where he pairs up with one
other person to try to take down some
kind of alien force Independence Day
launched Will Smith and it also
solidified who he was gonna be as an
actor as an action star Will Smith's
best moanin Independence Day is when he
punches the alien the face and says
welcome to earth he was so mighty that
he punched an alien wearing impenetrable
body armor and knocked him out for hours
that's not even its face it's just kind
of like an exoskeleton shell Will Smith
punches so hard you can punch your mech
suit and still knock you out
what a great just popcorn movie moment I
just always forget that his wife's a
stripper in them you're in a military
pension get your wife off the pole I
love him and goldblum walking back
victorious it's after they've defeated
the alien empire whatever and the ship
crashes and they walk out with the
cigars that's great
I love him dragon the alien and the
parachute she got me out huge dragon
you'll heavy-ass through the burning
Jesse if I saw an alien I would [ __ ] my
pants and Will Smith is just like
annoyed one of Will Smith's best
performances with out a doubt for me
it's the first men in black
I loved men in black when it came out
Will Smith is a cop dressed in
ridiculous 90s clothes and he chases an
alien Tommy Lee Jones hires him to
become a man in black and they saved the
world from a giant bug that eats sugar
and water and any time the action or the
pace of the movie is starting to slow
down Will Smith looks at something and
makes a wisecrack about it like I'm a
break this damn thing it was a fun alien
movie it wasn't a scary one it was like
gross and weird
it used animatronics and it used CG like
good like early CG Vincent D'Onofrio is
great sugar and waffle I need sugar and
water rubber water and sugar give me
sugar
it is really underrated people should
like him in that movie more than they
like Will Smith and his wife who's
played by Siobhan Fallon I love her even
though it's the small roles like I got
everyone on those trains is an alien oh
this person's famous but they're in
I think current celebrity aliens
Sylvester Stallone would still be there
let's go with Tom Brady Carson Daly
Tommy Wiseau is definitely hahaha you
must be kidding aren't you
I particularly enjoy the part of men in
black that tells you how to dance to it
talk about great songs there were other
words probably at some point wild wild
west is something I remember enjoying
wild wild west it's probably not a good
movie wild wild west is truly truly a
dumb movie eight absolute cluster F of
things that don't need to be in a film
at any point I don't understand why all
of you can't get on the wild wild west
train because it's a badass train Will
Smith is a sheriff Kevin Kline is like a
weird steampunk scientist and there's an
evil landowner with a big robot spider
I remember Salma Hayek had some great
dresses I think some of them were purple
Salma Hayek she's super hot and you got
explosions you have a big ass spider the
villain with the spider legs and then
the mecha spider this like spider stuff
going on
but tarantula why does this exist who is
the audience for this it was like a
steampunk Western alien hybrid musical
is there music in that I feel like
they're dancing at a certain point I
think that the song wild wild west is
great if you watch wild wild west then
to Marian you're like I have no idea
what I just watched guess what
Will Smith is going to tell you the
entire plot of the movie in song if I
could just get a Will Smith song at the
end of every movie that summarize the
whole plot for me that would be really
great if there's any movie that needed a
submariner up it was definitely Wild
Wild West I just sold myself on it again
why are we not watching this right now
yeah
I'm so sorry Billy that's not a good
movie yeah I didn't have a problem with
I am Legend like the concept is is
interesting in kind of a Twilight Zone
II way I am Legend is kind of like Will
Smith versus the zombie apocalypse
everyone else on earth is gone except
for him it's just about him and his dogs
Samantha living in New York trying to
catch and murder all of these zombie
things I am Legend is a really strong
film except for the CGI of the whatever
those people turn into the effects as
far as like the city being abandoned
their real stealing oppressive and Will
Smith gives a really good performance
man spoil there's the dog dies that was
terrible if you don't cry when he has to
kill his dog you sir have no soul that
is one of the most heart-wrenching
scenes of any movie ever seen that is
worse than being the last man on earth
it's worse than everybody else dying
forget Marley & Me it's I am Legend and
that dog is I am Legend different than
legends of the fall
[Music]
I think a lot of people credit in the
Penn State making Will Smith this big
star it was like his jump from TV to
film for me it was bad boys bad boys one
has everything that you want to see from
Will Smith put the gun down and give me
a peck of trouble the food bubblicious
he's wisecracking he's shooting stuff
he's running with his shirt off running
in slow motion he's chasing like a car
he's got great chemistry with Martin
Lawrence - not quite mega star actors
yet that are really trying to like step
it up with a whole lot of circular
camera shots guns explosions behind
merton rigs I'd be willing to put them
solid number two just sick so I see
something is wrong with you you have a
problem and you should have yourself
checked we do need more bad boys movies
why stop it - why - that's a weird
number movies are best in trilogies the
fourth one they go to space we need more
bad boys movies I didn't think bright
was as bad as everybody said it was was
it great no it takes a lot to tear the
charisma out of Will Smith and some how
bright did it a lot of people are
heating on this movie first of all is
free it's on Netflix it was a movie
where he was Will Smith in a role that
did not call for him to be Will Smith he
just does some real classic Will Smith
runs and absolutely none of them make me
like him in that movie so I need you to
take your fat Shrek looking ass back to
your vehicle and drive to come to Fiona
I'm pretty sure that they sold this
movie as training day meets Lord of the
Rings it's more like Warcraft meets
training day bright as every other David
Ayer movie meets acid it's just weird
he murders a fairy and then says fairy
lives don't matter when you're doing a
movie that is so heavy-handed with
social commentary you have to be careful
about the jokes and staff would even is
the commentary there yeah like what are
you saying what is this what are you
saying
this ain't no small talk this is big ass
talk you got kind of like the police
procedural kind of element to it but you
know they're cracking down on orcs and
goblins and stupid creature stupids I
mean it does sound dumb I feel like I'm
talking myself
but as I describe it I hate Will Smith
and bright and I love Will Smith I don't
think I've ever been more disappointed
in a movie than I was with Hancock this
was one of the worst superhero movies of
all time but almost so bad it's good oh
good job yeah Hancock got a great
premise but it didn't quite live up to
it he's this superhero who doesn't
really care about saving people he'll do
it but he'll do it with a bad attitude
and he's super drunk pull over and give
yourselves up quietly why not have a
drunk superhero flying around the guy
deserves the lawful oil steam of the
same today all time well I'm have a
drink some people are more likely to be
superhero when they're drunk call him
whiskey man the whiskey Mountain Will
Smith can write a song about that
[Music]
hich was great he's like a love doctor
and he falls in love with Eva Mendes and
like that's such a hot couple he's kind
of like a pg-13 version of Tom Cruise's
character Magnolia I think you may have
misunderstood what I do exactly he's
trying to advise Kevin James he's trying
to give him help love house next subject
never take dating advice from someone
that good-looking they don't know how to
actually talk to anyone they've never
had - yes I would take dating advice
from Will Smith why wouldn't I he landed
Jada and she didn't like him at first I
honestly don't think I would want any
advice from Will Smith on paper he seems
really cool but he was in Suicide Squad
[Music]
what are you some kind of stirs have
squad wool well that is a really bad
movie I don't even think of Suicide
Squad as being able Smith movie don't
make me shoot you I honestly think it's
a testament to how charismatic Will
Smith is that he dug something watchful
out of that movie cuz it's a bad movie I
actually think it's an underrated DC
film
I feel like Warner Brothers do knew what
they were doing when they hired Will
Smith I want to see Will Smith's
Deadshot I don't really care about any
of the other ones Will Smith as Will
Smith II as he isn't it lady you are
evil was hired to be Will Smith that's
the point he's not the problem Suicide
Squad I think there are lots of problems
but he's not one of them I mean he's
doing his best but the best part to
decide Squad is either Amanda Waller or
the credits
[Music]
collateral beauty is definitely a movie
where you can tell the screenwriter
thought I am making something brilliant
here and just didn't have anybody bring
him back down to earth this is the worst
movie ever made and Will Smith is in it
how it doesn't write letters to people
he writes to things he writes letters to
death time and love they're trying to
make him think he's crazy so that he's
declared insane but in the end it turns
out that they really were death time and
love it's the dumbest thing ever put on
film collateral Beauty what does that
even mean like something got prettier
just by accident
the phrase collateral Beauty is supposed
to be like a dumber version of like look
on the bright side like you know your
kid died but the collateral Beauty is
you got the room for a pool table I'm
not sure which actors should be most
embarrassed by being in this movie I'm
just most embarrassed that I saw this
movie
weird since this is completely and
arbitrarily rigged by us but it's a tie
so much like Will Smith's kind of
confused expression on this plate we're
gonna just stick them somewhere in the
back and hope you don't notice Joe hit
it in West Philadelphia born and raised
Will Smith was in between Star Wars and
Russell Crowe Joe do you know any other
Will Smith songs yeah honey in the week
Wild West born and raised Will Smith was
friends with Evan Clarence oh no hi
all right stop guys hope you enjoyed
that episode of smash hit let us know in
the comments below who what or when
you'd like us to do next
we'll probably ignore it and do whatever
we want hope you enjoyed
[Music]